From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
My name is Emilye Crosby and today is December 1, 2015.
And I'm here with Thames to Clarence McGee and we're at the University of Southern Mississippi from the McCain Library at the Royal History and Cultural Heritage Center.
The Center for the History and Cultural Heritage with me is John Bishop, who with us is John Bishop and Guha Shankar.
And we're here with the Civil Rights History Project, which is co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the National, the Smithsonian National Museum on African American History and Culture.
So thank you very much, Mr. McGee, for joining us today.
You're welcome.
I was wondering if you'd be willing to start by talking about when and where you were born and about your family.
I was born and Marion County, Columbia, Mississippi, in 1900 and, well, May 15, 1932.
I have two birth dates. I have May 14, which is officially by my mother's record because she was there.
She would have something to invest in.
Of course, the federal government came in late and said it's the 15.
In order to get benefits, I say 15, but I celebrate the 14.
Okay?
You're going to say, when you do it, you get all the energy.
So you have two birth dates.
I have two birth dates, of course.
Yeah.
And I'm the oldest of 10 siblings, five boys, five girls.
One of the girls have deceased two of the boys have passed on.
So they still leave seven of us.
Yeah.
And all at one time were married.
We all have children, you know, from two to five.
My parents are the late Glessie R. McGee and O'Reilly, Leggett McGee.
We grew up in the rural area of Marion County.
My dad initially was a sharecropper.
And he vowed before he ever married, if he had children, that he would make sure that they went to school.
So our money crop, for the most part, was cotton.
He eventually ended up purchasing photo acres of land with maybe about three acres for call.
That could be cultivated.
And he took an axe and he cleared off the new ground.
And we would come in after school and pick up the limbs and pile them up and burn them.
That, the portion that we didn't use for heating our home and preparing our meals.
I came up when there was no switch that you can flip and the heat come on, or the light comes on, or turn a faucet and get water.
All of that sort of come like out of the natural.
We were nature people.
We never went hungry.
We always had plenty to eat, not a big variety, because we grew everything.
We raised chickens, therefore we had our eggs and our chicken for eating and re-raised cows.
Therefore we had our milk and beef.
We raised hogs, therefore we had our pork.
We grew corn. We had to gather that for the winter.
We re-sweep potatoes. We have the galodos and bank them for the winter.
We got water from a spring.
Buckets or peels go down under the hill.
Packed the water back up the hills for drinking, for cooking, for bathing, for washing clothes, for feeding the lifestyle.
I guess that we're giving them, instead of not to waste the water.
It's insanity not to waste water, but it also developed a sort of discipline to work.
We grew up having to work because of necessity.
Everybody had to do that.
They're old-share.
Once you got big enough, you knew what you were supposed to do.
You tried to do it before, dark, because we had no electricity.
We had lamps.
We had fireplace.
We'd get down in front of a fireplace and do our studies.
I used, recall, you set up a pale and put some fat and candles on top of it to make a fire.
You can start it by that.
My dad may have been promoted to the sixth grade.
I've seen my mother actually experienced the sixth grade.
However, they didn't have the academic learning.
They had what older people call the fifth, they call it mother with that.
My dad was a very good trainer.
I used to train intentionally.
He taught us what to do, how to do it.
If we did not do it correctly, he taught us what we needed to do it to do it.
It was better to do job well, not do it at all.
Why spend extra time doing the same job a second time?
We learned real fast from his training.
He always encouraged us to read and to study.
My mother worked as a houseperson and a mother.
And in the field, chopping and holding cotton and corn and picking cotton.
Up until, say, about 10-13 or 11 o'clock,
leave the field, come home, prepare meals so that when we came home,
there was food for us to eat.
I might be going a little to four right now, but as it comes to my gesture of love on you.
You mentioned that your parents, your father might have finished sixth grade
and your mother, you weren't sure if she experienced sixth grade.
That's the reverse.
I got it wrong.
Yeah, just the reverse.
Did they miss not going further in school?
They did.
My dad, and of course, when he was younger, his dad was only on the form,
but then he did extra work in order to take them through the window months.
My dad tells the story about his dad promising he and his sister.
If you worked real well this week and come next Monday,
you guys can go to school.
They were excited about it.
So they got up early that Monday morning.
They took care of their wall and chores and got dressed and they sat on the porch
and went like, here's that awake.
He said to my grandma at that time, says, get those chores on up
because we got to go do some work.
See, so the chores were up there on the porch.
They were waiting to go to school.
Sorry, ain't nobody going to school here today.
I just made a contract with this guy to clean up a new ground.
That means I'm going to take an axe, I'm going to cut down the trees and the bushes and all that.
They got to go out there and pick them up and burn it.
Brought my dad his heart.
Made a vow that the L.I. had children, that they would go to school.
Did you have trouble keeping you on school?
Did you have a sacrifice?
No, it was not a sacrifice.
In elementary school and junior high high school, we enjoyed going to school.
It was a little bit a different style of life because we worked hard in the fields
and we worked hard to get everything done so that we could go to school.
Our lifestyle, having to do things inspired us to want to do something different.
We were not afraid of school, we wanted to go to school.
Once we finished high school, we might have been a little hesitant there.
He said to us, they would come a day when high school diploma will not be good enough.
They got to go further.
Of course, I'm the oldest, of course, so I'm the first who went to high school.
I went with the college, went further than high school.
I had some, a few setbacks.
I was in the All Corn A&M college.
It's All Corn State University now.
30 days to the day of my mother passed from childbirth,
which was a total wreck of my life.
I had to get the bus from Alcorn State University, Mississippi.
Someone took me from Alcorn State University, Mississippi to Vicksburg, Mississippi to get the bus.
The bus from Vicksburg, Mississippi took me all day to get to Columbia.
My dad and my aunt commit me at the bus station.
After the fuel, my dad says, if you want to go back, you can go back.
I had a choice.
I chose to go back.
Of course, I was not in any condition to make my grades.
I basically failed, but we had the second semester.
I sort of pulled myself together in that past.
The other tragedy that happened was just about one month into the second semester.
My dad came down with a diabetic or coma.
I didn't know he was diabetic, but my sister, who was there,
not who was next to me, was sort of like the person who kept everything together with my dad.
She said, my dad took ill and he couldn't lie down.
He couldn't sit up.
He was sitting in my younger siblings to the field.
The time of the year that you could take a hole and cut up the cool and stalks.
That's what they do, getting prepared.
He sent them out one door.
She went out to the back door and accepted them.
They said, no, go get my grandma.
Maybe three miles away.
They went to my grandmother.
My grandmother got a first customer man who had a car.
Came to pick my daddy up.
When they moved him from the bed to the car, that's when he went into a coma.
They took him to the hospital.
When he got the diabetes down on us so he could talk and everything.
He asked the doctor to get ready to release him.
He said, what must I do now?
I go back home.
He said, you don't go home.
Sit down.
You go home and work as hard as you ever work.
Then he put them on a diet.
Pretty much oatmeal.
No sugar.
I think he had the drawer in the table.
It would tell me whether the glucose was up or low.
But he graduated from that.
Eventually, it went in remission.
He lived to be like 84 years of age.
He died of diabetes.
He died of congestive heart failure.
All that tied into my school, I could have said after my mother passed, I'm satisfied.
That would have been a terrible mistake.
I could have said that.
I had to come home when daddy went to Nabil and stayed a whole week.
When he came back, if you want to go back, you can go back.
I think God I had the courage to go back.
I was there to finish.
That's tied in with their education and how we were motivated to go to schools and get degrees.
My daddy eventually married a couple of years after my mother died.
A person who was a teacher.
Of course, she had no children of her own.
That left by O. DeSister and two other sisters there, two brothers there.
What happened to the other brother and the other sister?
When we grew up there, we were across the lane from my dad's mother, my grandmother.
We loved to stay at Grandmomma's house.
My older brother loved to stay there more than anybody else.
When we finally moved from there to the property, my mother would not take this boy.
She let him stay there.
She raised him and when my mother passed, the two young siblings were a girl.
The baby was 18 months old and the other girl had to be in four years old.
My grandma took them in between her death and my dad had to get themselves out of the house.
She ended up raising those two girls.
She raised my older brother, two girls.
My older brother, when he got out of high school, he volunteered to go to the home service.
That left her with no boy.
She came to my dad's house and said, I came to get a boy.
My baby brother was there, heard it.
He volunteered.
She took him, but then when she got him by home, she discovered he had not been trained to plow.
She took him to trade him off to get the other brother.
The baby brother cried and said, that's okay, I'll keep you.
She ended up raising four months in for my family.
They could not go into place without permission from my dad.
My grandma would whip.
If you did something that you really need to whip me, I'm just going to tell your dad.
How far away did you go?
About three miles after that.
Three miles is further than it is.
It was close to the end.
We could run three miles.
Exactly.
We could run three miles across the field, across the past and get there.
I was wondering, not many people of your generation had the opportunity to go to college.
Sometimes they had to work.
I know you were working, but was it hard for your father to give up your labor to go to college or even to attend school every day?
I don't think it was.
It was not for hard for him to give it up.
It just made the adjustment.
I plowed on you.
It was so interesting going to school.
He would have to say to me, don't you burn my mule out.
You take a fur, you go to the other end, when you get to the end, you don't do it the laser wave.
Just stand there and pull them.
You pick up your plow and you make a swing.
The mule turn, you turn.
Boom.
You're going back the other way.
You're the same thing.
Boom.
A mule doesn't know when he's too hard or not too hard.
He had the caution.
Don't you get them, you're too hard.
When I left and went to college, I left one, two, three boys initially at the house.
Then I remember when my dad finally got a tractor, which I never got an experience to use.
He made it with that by having a tractor.
After the tractor, all of us had moved out.
He started a cattle instead of cotton.
He had at least 30 or 40 here in the cow.
Of course, that kept him close because he had to wash them at all the time.
He never knew who in a car if he was going to drop or when he had to get a vet in there
and come in to take care of the cows.
Then, of course, he finally got out of that and he did what he loved, even though that was a fish.
My dad, I never knew that you loved the fish.
When I was a boy, we never went.
The only time we went to fish, we went down on the creek and it was thick.
It was hot.
A lot of mosquitoes and the snakes.
If you didn't catch anything, you went down there to catch a meal, but you came by starving.
He said, I couldn't take a chance or maybe going to fish.
I had to do whatever produced the food right now.
It turned out to be a really good fish and he loved it.
He loved it.
That's schooling now.
The biggest training that my dad gave his children was picking cotton is a hot job.
Pick a cotton.
There's a slight in doing everything to make it easy.
Cotton grows in burrs.
You reach for a cotton out of the burr.
You make sure you get it the first time.
You can't be going two and three times in that burr.
One burr.
He would pay us one penny per pound.
If I picked 100 pounds a cotton a day, I earned a dollar for the whole day.
I didn't have to spend it on anything but myself because we had food at home.
We knew everything.
We grew it.
He taught us how to weigh our cotton.
Then he taught us to get a little pay to put our poundage and add them up.
This is schooling.
This is a train.
My dad was a trainer.
Whenever he took a bail a cotton to the gene and it produced seeds.
He would take the seeds and sell them all.
If he sold the seeds, he came back and he sat down and said,
okay, you're all come on now.
Figure out how much I owe you.
He paid each one of us a penny per pound.
Now, I learned to pick over 200 pounds a cotton a day.
Brothers and sisters, they're one or two who couldn't pick cotton.
Everybody can't do the same thing.
This can never pick cotton.
But the first time I beat my dad, my dad picked a cotton,
was the morning I came here and my sibling had gone to the field earlier.
I had milked the cows.
We had no pastures at that time.
You put a rope on your cow.
You take it to a green spot.
You stake it down so she can eat around that circle.
So I had to do some chores and do that.
So when I came with him, he scolded me for being late.
I got mad.
Unlike today, I darsely nothing to my dad.
I just beat him picking cotton.
You expressed with the same passion.
From that day forward, every day,
when I came at the same time, he did.
I didn't come at the same time.
I beat him picking cotton.
I don't know if I just get this idea.
No, he didn't do that in purpose.
But he did.
He motivated me.
What were your schools like coming up?
That's a different story.
Initially, from elementary school up until maybe I was about...
Ten years of age, I started early at age five.
We would walk from where we live,
better than a mile to catch a bus.
My aunt's husband had made a bus, a bought a bus,
and he used the bus to pick children up to take the school.
I think the school's supplemented that.
But we'd walk that mile and a half.
Hard, rain, cold, whatever to get that bus.
I only remember maybe one time not catching the bus.
Of course, my dad would be in the motorview that he was.
We don't miss buses.
I was standing up there in the rain, under a perconjury.
Many more than one is waiting.
Now, the white kids had a bus that drove it by the house.
It was not a homemade bus.
A real bus.
Did you think about that at the time?
At the time, it didn't bother you that much.
It really didn't.
Books were books that had been used for five years,
because there were other kids named written in the books.
So we had them in our books.
The parents of the school had to cut wood to heat the schools
in a winter time.
So they had to use a pack of a stack of wood out there.
They would bore well at the school,
so you can get water from the well.
There were no indoor plumbing.
There was no indoor restroom.
Everything was under the hill away from the school.
So you can imagine what that was like, rain, cold, whatever.
Smelly, you know.
But we didn't know we went poverty.
We learned that once we saw the TV,
we turned my people in poverty.
That motivated a lot of kids.
Some of them didn't.
A lot felt along, by the way, side.
Their parents were loggers,
put woodholders, stump holders.
And they made a little money,
so that was exciting to their kids.
And they were so their kid would go out and make a living
in the neighborhood.
My dad had a little close to tidal rain on us,
and generally people in the neighborhood
because he focused on education,
a whole lot more than others did.
And of course, once the neighborhoods knew that,
they helped to keep us in the right path.
We, you know, want to run with the group of boys,
and they see us, and I'm going to tell you that.
That's all they need to say.
We straighten up.
And so it kept us out of a lot of trouble.
So...
I was raised out at Alcorn,
so I'm especially curious.
But I was wondering if you could tell me what Alcorn was like
because I tell you.
You were raised at Alcorn?
Yes, sir.
Okay.
In 1973.
1973.
I went out there in 1950.
It was just a cattle path
from lawmen to Alcorn.
I mean, at some places you couldn't meet another vehicle.
You had to tell the Jews a place where you meet another vehicle.
It was either up and down around,
and that's just the way it was.
Well, in the one-a-time,
the buildings were heated by a boiler.
If everything worked well, you had heat,
but if it didn't, you didn't have heat.
Of course, you had...
the buildings were old,
and of course, we got a problem with that.
The children who were 10-hour-con
or rural children came from the country, basically.
Being an agriculture school, they raised portraits,
so you could work at the portrait plant.
As a student, as a part of your student A,
you could work at the slide-hog place.
Other things you could do,
that's you didn't grow in a vegetable bus?
They had to do it.
They did.
Yesterday it's here because we kept...
they were always planting milk
and pulled because they raised the whole stack of that.
They were all in the eye.
They grew all of that.
We were very close to nitpick,
because there were no nightlights close by.
That's one of the reasons I chose to go there.
I didn't feel within myself that I could go up to a city school
and not be affected by the nightlight.
I know one summer
with the agricultural department.
It stayed a week out there,
so I knew about it.
They were quite strict on boys and girls
being separated at certain point.
They were required to go to the vegetable service on Sunday evening.
They were Sunday school class on Sunday mornings.
In the back part,
we only got two meals doing the on Sundays.
Of course, coming from the country,
we got three meals per day.
You had to develop not having foods on Sunday evening.
I think they might give you a bag with an orange or something
and a brown bag.
Of course, they have the PX round on the chapel back there.
They would go around and get some candy bars and stuff like that.
If you had the money,
but people like me, I had no money.
Two issues was very long,
but then I worked to take care of my room in board.
I did.
They had a model home there
for the senior home makers
where they went in and spent,
I don't know where,
but I worked in the first semester
where they had to do meal planings
and all this kind of stuff
and practice purchasing meals
and preparing meals
and do all the things you know I'm going to do.
I worked there for, I don't know how long,
but taking care of the floors of that building.
Then one year I worked at the PES control.
The big bags of baits
and I'd have to take it
and put it in small package
and then distributed it wherever there were miles and so forth.
Then one time I worked as a person
who had taken out the garbage off the female dom hall.
I got the name of KT,
all my close friend, Nume SKT,
KOTAKT.
That's a nickname you want to carry to life, right?
Well, let's say look, I learned that.
These things are said to get a reaction,
but I learned how not to react.
If you say, hey, KT, KT,
how are you doing?
Only you and I know what we're talking about.
So what's the problem?
You learn how to respond or not respond.
What did you study at all of the core?
I went to service.
Two-year service.
I was drafted.
Before I left school,
my dad knew the draft lady.
As long as I was in school, I got deferred.
I come home for summer and go back to school
so my senior year, she sent me a draft notice
before the year was over.
With a handwritten note,
if you're not ready to go right now,
you just ignore it.
So I finished,
and then a couple of months after I finished,
then my draft came up and I went in.
Was that just an informal agreement?
That was a policy.
No, that was not a policy.
I can't remember where the lady who was managing the draft board.
But anyway,
somehow he got acquainted with her.
And she, I agree.
As long as I was in school,
I could be deferred.
If I wanted to leave, I could have gone.
But I'm glad I was able to say.
What did you do after service?
After service, I came back.
When I went in service,
I was living in La Mare in County.
In La Mare in County.
And I said,
La Marion, La Marion, La Mar-.
That was the name of the school.
La Mare.
La Mare in La Mare in vocation high school.
I left, I taught a month there
in between graduating in the time I was to leave.
And when I was at this church,
we was living here and had a spirit then.
So my dad had a sister,
my wife, and purchase in a home here
that belonged to his sister-in-law
that will move on the way.
So, when I was in Germany,
it went to homeless purchase.
And I had it in my name to it after I got by home.
So it was your own home.
Were you, um,
moving to move to Hamburg?
No, it just an opportunity that I married
while I was in service.
And my wife was,
I met her in Mare in County.
And she was working there.
And I came home on a furlough.
We got engaged before I,
they said, take two furloughs.
Got engaged.
And then they went back and got orders to go to Germany.
They gave me 30-day furlough before I went.
So I came back home and I got there while I was here.
And then I left and went to Germany for 11-14 days.
So it's in between that period
that the house became available.
And the house was purchased.
So when I came out of service,
I ended up here.
Was your wife working in Hattiesburg then?
Yes, she got in the job here and has very thin.
Was she a teacher too?
Yes.
What level was she teaching at?
She was in high school at the time in Mare in County.
And when she came here, she worked at Roe Inn in the high school.
She worked there until Lillie Burney School School was constructed.
Then she went to Lillie Burney School School.
And then after Lillie Burney School School,
during the early part of desecligation,
she went to Hopkins.
And then I took her away from the city in 74.
We went to Mobile.
I started working with the Federal Government.
But in between those times,
I did teach in as well.
When I came out of service in 56,
I got a job in Wiggins.
I feel like an unexpired term,
a previous teacher for some reason, that go.
So I worked there for one year.
Then I worked at Prentiss Institute for two years
in the high school department,
but coached the college basketball team.
Then I got a job here.
It started at Elemina Rescue.
And I came in.
I taught a combination of six and seven graders combined.
There was one full-time,
there was one full-class, seven-graders,
one-foot, six-graders.
And the overflow I had come by.
So I did that probably like three years.
And then when Lillie Burney School School opened,
I went to Lillie Burney School School as well.
And I left Lillie Burney School School in 1969,
and I went to Rowan high school.
And I left there.
I went with the Southern Mississippi Platinum Development District
for approximately two years.
And after that in between that,
I got employment with the Federal Government Department of Agriculture,
Food and Consumer Service.
I retired from them.
But in order to take that job,
I needed to move to Mobile.
So that's when I went to Mobile in 74.
And I worked from 74 to 95.
Came back to Hattiesburg, Mississippi.
But I was still in the same job,
but my office was located in Jackson.
So I worked there about three years before I retired.
You knew Jackson?
Yeah.
And it was not bad because at that time,
we had to start working,
compress hours, ten hours a day, four days a week.
So you didn't have to go five days?
I didn't have to go five days.
But that program started when I was in Mobile.
The day the staff decided what days they were going to take off,
I was in the field.
And so when I came back,
and that was Monday.
Can you believe Monday?
I go to work.
I have Monday off.
I go to still Wednesday Thursday and Friday.
So I leave here on Tuesday morning.
It's been Tuesday night, Wednesday night, Thursday night with my sister.
Friday I'm back at home.
Friday night, Saturday night, Sunday night, Monday night, home.
That's a pretty good situation.
Godless half of people who are...
Facing.
Whatever you're doing, you're doing.
I could probably go back and figure it out.
So did you move the handlebar like in the late fifth?
Fifty-six.
So were you willing to service them when the round decision came?
Oh yes.
A good fact.
Was that something that you were thinking about or aware of at the time?
I was aware of it.
Since it was over young, it was not here.
So you're not at that age, you're not a whole lot concerned about.
I was aware of it.
How did you...
Like, what was your first sort of awareness of race?
Since I was about eight and a half years old, I guess.
Sure.
Is that going to town?
Going to town, but look.
In the south, the relationship between a black family and a white family could be just like this.
That's not race.
My dad is share crowd with the white family who taught school in the school year.
And during this school year, we could move from our house to their house,
which was tight, had windows and huge fireplace.
And we could...
In the springtime, we go back to our house, which was up off the ground,
had shutters for windows,
had a huge living room and a kitchen, not holes in the floor, pick it roof on top,
we'll crack send it.
So when a rain came down, you had to put peels out to catch the water.
When we lived in their house, doing their abs and out of...
We didn't have that problem.
We could hear the wind outside, you know, whistling that kind of...
But in our house, we could feel the winds.
Yeah, you know, cracks in the wall.
The wall became our library because they were used newspaper, not newspaper.
Yeah, and cover them up with.
So we see pictures from study.
And then when it...
And the fall of the year before we moved there, we could touch the goats through the nother...
The pigs, through the nother, you know.
So it was a relationship there that we didn't have when we went to town.
I can remember clearly, on two occasions, one time I was downtown, very young.
I walked into something like a pool hall and people of color, they're going there.
They're wondering what they're doing in front of us.
And they are in the car.
Many issue me out the back door.
But, you know, back on the street, nothing happened.
And I remember once walking down the street in the car coming.
I don't know how close, but it was with inches of hit and it didn't get you to look at that close.
And when we would go to work from my house, we had to pass right by the family my dad is sharecrawled with.
If we ate at that house, we ate on the back porch within eight inside our house.
We sit on the back porch.
This is the family where you would sit in their house.
So you have to live in their house, but when they were there, you would eat on the back porch.
Yeah.
Would they ever eat at your house?
No.
So, you watch what your parent did or did not do.
And they may, I mean, not say anything, but you tell by that action that there are some places you don't go.
Or some things you don't say.
So, you learn to follow the leaders.
You got good leaders.
So, you're aware of it.
Of course, now I'm direct experience and participation is two different things.
You know.
And that's what I'm going to say.
So, what first cut you, what was your first awareness of the civil rights movement?
1956, when my dad and my wife purchased our first home.
He said to me, now that you own a home, you can pay a $2 poll tack and you can register to vote.
I'm not sure that he's registered at this time.
That was actually the one, then, yeah.
So, he's telling you about it.
He's telling me about it.
So, you own a home, you got to pay property tax.
Every time I go pay my property tax, I pay my poll tax.
So, I started going to the clerk office, exercising my right because I pay poll tax to register to vote.
You get caught off guard.
The first time I went in, a deputy clerk met me at the desk and asked what I wanted.
I told the other members, he said the register is not in today.
Well, what is his hours?
Well, he didn't keep regular hours.
So, what am I supposed to do?
She walk away, and I'm not going to stand up.
That's all I walk away.
It's 12 months probably later, I go back and do this lane, go through this lane routine.
This time he's in.
His name is, come on up there and lean.
Who went before him?
Cox.
Yes.
I met the same deputy at the Caroline, she says, what do you want?
I told her, she called him from the back, he walked up, I'm standing there, he says, what do you want, boy?
I told her, who sent you, boy?
I said, nobody.
You better wait.
He walks away.
I walk away.
The next time I go by, you know, you're in a row.
How did you feel?
I didn't feel the best at that time.
You're like a shock treatment.
You know, here I am.
I've done everything you're supposed to do, and you're saying, what you want, boy, you better wait.
And you're not even holding the conversation as to why I should wait.
You're going to walk away.
So the next time I go, he is no longer around, I think he's deceased maybe.
The only one is there.
And by this time, they are requiring you to fill out an application and give your section from the Mississippi Constitution.
You copy that on to the application process, and then you interpret it.
And in the application, you have to identify your precent where you would vote.
And having not voted before, that's a big task.
But luckily, they write the precent number on your poll tag receipt.
I remember.
So I put it on there.
But when he looked at it, he says, not quite satisfactory.
And he garrons.
He walks away.
No conversation.
What is your father's name told you that?
Were you talking to anybody about his time?
Not really.
And I guess one of the reason why is I'm still working basically out of town.
I'm here on the weekend.
I will come on the night out of town.
So I'm not really carton of the fact that others are being treated the same way.
So it takes me a couple of two or three years to realize that I'm not the only one that's been given this cold shot.
Did you like that but try to register?
Oh yes.
She did three times.
She took the test three times.
I took her six.
I think they have recorded five times.
So she was more and more females are more challenging than males.
And that's the reason because they're free.
The male is not free.
The female is.
Because she raised a question of what you mean out there in past.
I know I passed it.
So she's getting a little bit ficing.
I said, hey, you won't get me in trouble.
We've got to go.
But anyway, she took it three times.
And she recognized for some reason that it was the present that was hanging her up.
But it also said, if you don't know the present just put in a nearest town, she wrote "Hattiesburg." which means she's met all the requirements.
There is nothing that had missed.
And yet he said, not quite satisfied.
And she went on a wide.
I can't tell you.
Walks away.
I took her out.
So we never found out until the third court took them to Thurinland to court.
We're along with about 46, four or four of the people, mainly who were teachers,
were subpoenaed to be at those trials.
And actually she got on a witness, and I didn't.
So she claims that her witness wrote the whole thing open.
And she's probably right.
Because when they prosecute us, I want to thank his name.
I know it, but I can't remember tonight.
So who is this the federal?
The federal, fifth-circle court of the appeal.
The door.
The door?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Took her application and used it as comparison with a white gentleman of a royal spring,
who was a truck driver, who could not read, could not write.
He had taken the test and passed it.
So he really got two applications.
One from a white gentleman, one from a lady of color.
He passed here, and so when he questioned him about it, I think, of course I'm not in there.
They said, there's a white race on you.
He said, I haven't run a race.
What color are you?
Oh, I'm white.
You know, it was a challenge, but then I started treating it as a cat and mouse game.
Because every time I got a chance to go back in, I would go.
So we got, we knew each other quite well.
Because I would go, and he'd give me the test.
I'd walk in and say, hey, you said, you got 15 minutes.
Give me the test.
All I wanted was the test.
Because I was studying the Constitution.
I knew it wasn't getting me on that.
And he wouldn't get me on the pre-scent because you got it right here on my pole,
and I actually see what I might have been made up.
I really didn't think.
Somebody's playing somebody, so...
When you were saying the Constitution, is that something you were doing on your own?
Oh, no, oh, no.
It was the NAACP.
That's all I wanted.
No, no, it was not core, or native discipline.
Yeah.
There was all my own.
How did you all find out about the lawsuit?
We were subpoenaed.
So that was the first you heard about it with the municipality?
No, we had taught, I guess, they had interviewed us.
I'm not sure.
At that point, we were aware that it was going to get to the point, the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeal.
But we had been in an interview.
I know that when they were doing that case, and they were doing similar, a couple similar cases,
they would try to subpoena the records, and they were having trouble getting me the records
from the Circuit Court office.
So did they know about your applications from the records, or did they know about it from the records, or somebody?
I think they would have gotten them from the records, because their land was taken in this time,
because it was being held in contempt.
He had been in court before, had been ordered to stop making the difference between races, but he never stopped.
So the records were the way they threw it.
I knew that they really pursued it with him.
Did you ever work with my drivers?
Did you mean that?
I do make, in fact, I was in school at all, or with my kids.
So he was there at the time?
Yeah, he was in the same time.
He was finishing up there.
Yeah, his wife and I were in the same class.
I finished in the summer, and when I left the campus, he gave me a ride from the campus.
So I had contact with him, and then of course, as I got more involved in NAACP,
we had much more interaction from that level.
I got a little bit involved with the NAACP, then.
Well, the president of this kind of branch at that time was J.C. Fairley.
We attended the same church.
So this is where my first connection came with membership within NAACCP.
So would he speak at church, or would you talk to people after church about it?
Which JC would?
Yeah, he was quite a spokesman.
Yeah, and you just put me in the side of John.
It didn't take a whole lot, really, and true, but just one request in I mean it.
What was your motivation?
I know it seems obvious, but it's one I'm trying to put it in.
I had experience when I was in the servers that really heightened, I guess you say,
that's sensitive to it.
I was in Fort Eustis, Virginia, and there was a young man who was a manager from somewhere in Ohio,
who was a white young man.
He had been to a church near the camp, and he was invited to speak.
And on the day before he went out, he asked if I would go with him out there,
and I said, yeah, but then I'm sure I can go.
Oh, yeah, I'm sure, I'm sure.
Virginia?
Yeah, Virginia, yeah, I'm sure, I'm sure.
So one of the church members came over, picked us up, drove us to the church.
We got there between Sunday's Goom and Worship's servers from my teenage.
My habit was when I got the church, I would go inside, and we're not staying outside,
unlike I saw a whole lot of people do.
So I went in, and I picked up a bulldozer, and I was sitting over there looking at them, not paying attention.
And he came in with tears in his eyes and says, we can't stay here, we can't stay here.
That says why?
We stay there, we won't have church.
Oh.
So they brought us back to the camp.
And that's one thing that really, you know, stand out.
I mean, it's just out in society, it's one thing, but in church, that's gross.
What church did you use to stay away?
St. James, Christian Methodist, Episcopal Church, yeah.
Did, were there a lot of people in the congregation that joined the end of the list behind you?
Procly everybody were problem members in that church, yeah.
And if my church knows the same way, with small membership, or procly everybody,
they're all members of the NAACP.
We encouraged them to do that, and they will, they follow our leadership in that respect, yeah.
Were you, once you joined the sacred faith in were they all the meetings?
I did not attend a lot of meetings when I initially joined.
At the time, I went on, I got involved, and then a little more involved doing the Freedom Sun.
And we did sensitivity, especially for youngsters from the North, and it was, as we came down.
Since we knew the culture, we did a lot of sensitivity training, round circus,
talking about what you can expect, or if you say this or you say that,
and some eras of what, they were accustomed to calling, policemen's pigs,
we say you can't do that here, you can't call them pigs, you can use something.
That's just one example.
They were encouraging and trained, they were cis, but then we knew where the danger spots were.
We knew what comments would set people off and things like that.
So we did a lot of sensitivity training, not only here, but other part of the state.
I got acquainted with the president who succeeded, JC Ferler, which was Dr. C.E. Smith,
he and his family, and I became more involved, more involved with the NAACP serving on committees, and things of that sort.
What was the committee?
I remember one, a specifically education committee, and that's what we did.
We certainly own a baratia committee in helping the city school develop a strategy for integrating the schools.
Was that before or after freedom?
Probably after freedom summer.
Yes, yes, yeah.
And at that point, are you teaching at Rowan?
Lillie Burney School School.
And then Rowan I were in 1969, that's when I started.
Lillie Burney School School, all great slow.
The two places, yeah.
We were just talking to Mr. Smith earlier today.
So what was it that got you more involved, you know, or do you really want to become more involved?
My tutor.
We had two daughters, and I did not want them to inherit what I inherited.
So everything I did was with them in my...
How old were they in summer 64?
My oldest was born in 59.
No, no, no, no, 57.
The baby was born in 59.
Did they go to freedom schools?
No, they didn't go to freedom schools.
You kept them home.
Now, we're not worried.
We did for them what they needed to have done.
We're not worried about that.
I just want to keep on at home.
Yeah.
Well, that didn't stop us from working with the freedom summer.
Without church, provided houses, and for some of them, provided meals for some of them.
So we were involved, but we didn't put our shoes on out there.
We were involved.
What are some of the things that you were all were doing?
I mean, you just said housing.
Can you give me a sort of a sense of what the day-to-day was like?
Well, not...
Of course, you know that there were leaders identified as leaders who were at various churches,
where the students would come in and have the classes.
And so, my provide me for them in some form of recognition,
which is like a regular school, but mostly dealing with a civics citizenship.
I guess we're backing up before freedom summer.
When did you meet or work with any of the young people that came in with SNCC or COPE,
like Hollywood Walkings or E&C,
that I was too damaged on.
I did not work with those persons,
per se, knew about them, but...
Wasn't there any other extra ones coming in?
Yeah, yeah.
I think the biggest portion of my involvement was doing the sensitivity training,
and things like that.
Sure, that was the community.
Yeah.
But the expectations were, how do you say?
Can you...
So, the biracial community,
said you were working on a plan or a strategy for disavagating the schools,
what were those meetings like?
I learned early in my involvement that the meetings there were,
the meetings that were 10 were the second meetings.
The meetings had been held prior to our meetings.
So, we learned to, as people of color, to come together on our education meeting,
and role play.
We were proposed questions that we were going to propose
and we'd have somebody respond to those questions,
so that when we got in the meeting,
we would be conditioned to what might have been said.
And also, we suggest a question that might be coming to us,
be prepared to answer those.
Specifically, remember Dr. Spinks,
who was Superintendent of the School,
and Mr. D. R. Patrick, was,
I believe who was principal of
Blair High School School, Mrs. Erling Boas,
who was the chair of our education committee.
I'm a minister, I don't know if I'm going to come in.
I'm going to try to remember with other person,
but I remember in meetings where these two particular
gentlemen were involved.
D. R. Patrick was a man of...
I was a hyper-tanchor.
And he was free with his emotion.
He was stand up and put his finger in your face.
Erling Boas was chair of that committee.
And she said, don't point your finger in my face.
He may take it down, but the next three minutes is back up there,
and then she would put her right in his face.
So we spent a lot of time trying to make sure.
Trying to manage the people within the meeting
so that we get to some point that we can do some positive.
But anyway, they weren't interested in meetings.
But the challenge.
You can even go back to that fire in your head
and think about what you hoped would come out of it.
Obviously, you lived all these years in the scene
and how it's turned out.
Do you remember what your hopes were at the time?
We used the word freedom and we used it all to loosely.
But without tying it down, I'm not sure we knew what the word freedom
encompassed.
Freedom of expression, freedom to go to school wherever you want to go.
Free from being harassed.
We were harassed. We were terrorized.
The word terrorist is not new.
We lived it all our lives.
Did you have direct threats on your family?
No, not really.
My wife had a call doing the trial at Reveal World.
She said, I don't know what you were thinking about this
court situation.
She said, my thoughts are reserved to you.
During the trial.
I wasn't every day in the quarters of the courthouse.
There was a white gentleman.
We happened to be me, and it happened with the whole entire.
It was intending to put a shoulder into me.
Of course, I realized what he was doing.
When he got to the point, he wanted to put the shoulder.
I was just slide away.
He didn't want to go into the whole entire world.
Right where the city jail is now was a park and
put much parking meters in front of it.
My car was an apporacan lot.
When I went out of the courthouse,
I saw a pickup truck.
I got standing outside, talking to the morning side.
I got in my car.
I came right by them.
That way you get two length everywhere.
I came right here at the corner of the post office,
turning left on the pile, went to Main and turned right.
Then I noticed a pickup following me.
When I got down to Walnut Street,
I used to be a traffic light just across the river over there.
I hesitated until the green went off in caution,
and I ran into caution.
They ran in red light to follow me.
When I got down to Katie,
I Katie, hauled across the Winoboam Katie.
I lived a whole, but I lived on the east side.
I took Katie and I went west.
They followed me.
All of a sudden I just hit my brakes real quick,
pulled the side and accept them noticing they would have right over me.
I got off full and then when they passed me,
I just followed them.
At the point I stopped and I turned right and came back.
They just went, I got one call at one time.
It's about to ask me something about the kings
and made the rocket tour to Mark.
I hear that he, what did he say?
Excuse me, I was right.
I hear that he sucks.
I said, you probably know he probably had you last night.
I didn't understand.
He just said, your life was quick.
I guess you practiced on each other.
I learned from her.
She taught you how to talk back.
I'm not sure.
Eve asked you, can you say what your wife's name is?
Carey.
See, ARRI, Bradley, like a...
Carey Bradley, and it seems like you two are well matched.
We have, we have been, now we're getting to the point
where we want to be left alone now.
After 60 years.
We retired from pay jobs, but we never retired
from working in a community, working in WACP
and in the church, mission, how we're going to all that kind of stuff.
We never retired from that.
But, in fact, we had got more rest when we got paid for it.
I was going to say, that's why you're so young.
I didn't know.
When you mentioned Dr. Smith, and you just now mentioned Mr. Dr. King,
we were talking to Mr. Smith, and we heard a story about her sneaking Dr. King into town.
But we didn't actually get her to tell that story on tape, do you know about it?
I know about it, but I have to let somebody else tell it.
Unfortunately, I didn't stay for the meeting.
He was late.
And of course, at that time, I was working, I think, in Waynesboro,
And having to get up early in the morning to drive there,
I didn't get a chance to stay because I went home and got some rest so I can get up to the next morning.
And that's what happened.
Do you know the story of how she smucked him in?
I've heard the story, but I don't know if I've heard it from her.
Okay.
So I bet us all to leave it.
Or it is there.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
You didn't hear the tell.
What was that about, right?
What did you hope school desegregation would work like?
What were you working for on the committee trying to accomplish?
Better supplies.
I think that was better supplies.
And I don't think I was expecting...
Because I felt that teachers were doing a pretty good job.
Could be a better job if they had the equipment and supplies.
We never had a poor lab.
I told you earlier we would use some books that would ten years old, something.
Supplies equipment.
I was not necessarily thinking about...
I want to say rubbing shoulders with other races and so forth.
Just give us a fly.
Let us go where...
Why did I have to leave Hadisburg together a graduate degree?
I think that was uncalled for.
That this university closed a college terms and they had graduate programs.
And it didn't make sense to you.
The state would give you a little money to go to a school outside of the state.
You have to come up with a restaurant.
Fortunately I had been in service.
So I got my G.I. bill to help me out in there.
People of color didn't do too bad with what they had.
There have been some backlash.
There have been some false notion as to what freedom means.
There is a lot of motivation that we did on our own that we are not doing any.
But now...
I use the term freedom I never has been, never will be.
Freedom you think you have can be lost if you do nothing.
Because freedom incurs a huge responsibility.
You've got to get uncomfortable.
You've got to get tired.
And I said, hey, I got it made.
I said that cheer that's killing me right now.
I'd have been there 10 years ago.
So you need to be doing something.
And there is enough blame to go around to everybody who put on my dress.
Everybody who put on pants.
When it comes to the life of proper exercise and your responsibility as a resource.
We just take voting for example.
When I didn't have the car a hunger, a thirst for it.
I used my hand.
I had a struggle for it though.
But now that 30 seconds out, three minutes you've got it already in your hand.
What is it?
Angle count.
There's a specific video card still.
I've got a card.
You've got a vote ID.
No, well, vote ID is something.
I don't know what they do with that.
But they give you a vote restoration card.
Yeah, they may let so you...most time.
But I think...
And I keep using the word false notion of freedom.
It's been the biggest disappointment that I see.
So if you don't struggle for it, you really don't have the same appreciation as people who struggle.
Well, I've got to drive my dad's car.
Couldn't care anything about tires.
I had to worry about the oil though.
He taught me.
Pay attention to the oil and water in my car.
Oil and water.
Never said a thing about tires.
Never said a thing about gas.
I'm not going to run that.
Yeah, because if the tires blow out, you're going to stop.
If the gas can't stop.
But it'll keep running without water and oil until it burns.
It took me a long time to understand why he said that and didn't say the other.
But he was training.
Did you end up LACP trying to recruit the first students who went to a free amount of choice for their families who are going to?
Sure, there was some recruitment.
I don't think the recruitment was not that difficult.
Everybody was in the same boat.
Everybody was either hungry or thirsty for education in the same boat.
And education was the ticket for the way out.
We live in a society today.
We have to cut wood.
Who has to bring water in?
Who has to take care of all the chickens' cars?
Who has to worry about the water?
He just flippled the switch.
He got it comfortable.
All the things that we want we can get.
And the things that this has no eyes.
Poverty has no eyes.
People who have not been somehow educated either in the schools or the family or whatever.
Basically get what they want.
Or somebody else will give them what they need.
And the worst is the incentive to do better.
But we're free.
I visit it and this is different.
Part of my job initially with the federal government was to visit stores,
whole training for how you handle food stamp, authorizing,
and the state human resources.
From the administrative part of the check on that.
And that also took me into homes of people who got benefits and things like that.
The first home I saw a cell phone with people who were needing a welfare and that kind of stuff.
And it took me a long time.
And of course, that's when they had these boxes in the boxes.
When I finally got one, I was still a mobile and I never used it until I came over here.
My wife was having to drive from mobile to you to take care of her dad at the time.
But we came here that cut out 100 miles.
But she still had to go some one more and I got up and said,
look, I got this little phone here.
Never use it.
Let me hook it up in your car, turn it on, test it by calling them back in the house to see if it worked.
And I tested it in it worked.
I said, now if you have a problem, all you have to do is pick it up and call home.
She left here, went up to 59 and 49.
Got her her car, took gas up, put a purse down by the station, get tank,
drove off and left it.
The attendant saw it when I picked it up, opened it up, found an address, she called me.
I said, okay, I come up and pick it up.
She was in Georgetown, Georgetown, this is a sick to my wife when she discovered that she didn't have it.
She picked up the phone the first time we ever used it, called me.
So I don't have it, I said, okay, I got it.
What must I do?
Come back, as you can get a ticket coming back.
So I'm not going to go to Mama.
I'll be up in a few days and I bring it to you.
It took me a long time.
But this is a dragon.
A lot of people losing jobs and everything because they don't know how to handle this technology.
That's not part of what you asked for.
I'm sorry.
Did you tell them participate in school and this event?
So we sent them to private kindergarten and with the private kindergarten and about the time they got into the public school.
Then of course, my kids was in the tenth and the eleventh grade.
They went with the Hawkins Junior High School.
Yeah.
The other one went to Blair High School because she was a senior when we left.
They were going away.
So in the nitty gritty part of it, I said to her, they were not exposed to it.
Do you know what the experience was like to children that were the first ones?
Only what I hear.
We've heard that just recently.
We had a 50-year celebration of the first students who went into the elementary schools who came, who told their stories.
It's not just past.
Did any of the black teachers and high school teachers have any of them losing jobs when they could have unified those districts?
None that I know of lost their job.
The high school was a unique situation.
Dr. N.R. Burger, a principal at the principal of N.R. Burger.
I don't know if he has Dr. Nott.
People say he did not get involved much, but he was in the politics.
Where the county school teachers were dismissed, if it was known that they were a member of the NAACP, the city's teachers were not.
So he saw it like a buffer between his teachers and people who would do them all.
That was something that happened recently, building a town.
Oh yeah.
The year I was at Rowan, the student who walked out of school and marched from Rowan to over on Mobile Street.
That was 6.9, of course, we were in.
I went with them.
I think a couple of the teachers went with, not everybody.
We went as monitors to be sure that they did not agitate the policemen and things like that.
It caused them to react in a negative way.
For the graduation that they for some reason,
who was asserted as one of the sponsors for the graduation that year.
Mr. N.R. Burger invited myself to work with him, Mr. Spinks from the school building,
across over to the football stadium where we were here at the graduation that night.
He knew my involvement, you know, other people knew my involvement.
And I guess the one of the reasons I accept an offer to do something other than teacher is because of the extent of my involvement.
And I realized, of course, the other offer paid me twice as much now.
It was not bad.
It caused me to realize that if Dr. Spinks, at the end of the school term said,
McGee, I don't have anything for you to do, I'm out.
But I wouldn't make anything in the first place.
Other job had the same opportunity to say the same thing, but at least I made something.
So I took a chance on doing that.
The teachers didn't have any tenure?
No. If we decided he didn't need you.
And especially if you've been involved.
And because from that standpoint, I don't, you know, we didn't suffer the wrath as some of the countless did.
Because of what we were doing.
And who was crazier, both.
There's one other thing that happened during this period.
In 1962, I believe it was.
Because of my activity.
My wife and I were subpoenaed along with one other black man, T.F. Boyne,
to go to Aberdeen, Mississippi, to be witnesses that Clyde Kennard was still alive.
He was in Parchman Farm at the time.
And I know, she'll forget it. We left here on the north.
I think it was like December the 21st.
I don't think it was 62. Very cold.
The early end was supreme.
I don't know. About two of the wife was supreme.
Because they passed us on our way up.
We got to Aberdeen. We went into the courthouse.
And we sat and then brought Clyde Kennard in from the side, to near the chamber.
We waited him. He waited us.
Just to be witness.
Now my wife and I co-star in that background. We're teachers.
We could see if one of us had been subpoenaed and somebody wanted to take a retribution against it,
then the other would have a job.
But both we went. Not knowing what would happen.
I know who's subpoenaed.
Yeah, R. Jess Brown, attorney, R. Jess Brown did it.
There were only two black attorneys that I knew of in the state.
Jack Young and R. Jess Brown.
I don't understand the purpose.
Well, the government had ordered the, what the writ of papers' corpse,
had ordered them to prove, show that he was still alive.
I see because of the condition.
Yeah, condition of even that.
What did he look like at that time?
He was real dark.
Now I know that he's on key more something, but I mean,
truly, really, a real dark, complacent.
Didn't look ill.
Well, from a distance, we only just waved through him,
and that's it.
And that was it.
We had done our job, now we've come back, see that.
And then I knew everything that it was involved in,
but I had not personally met him.
Did you know, how just Brown, did you know, I'm several years old?
I knew him from trials, he and Jack Young had held here.
So they knew you because of the voter registration.
I'm sure, I'm sure, I'm sure that's it.
I never knew about that.
I'd never heard about that.
I was going to witness that he was still living.
Did you know Vernon Dahmer?
I knew Vernon Dahmer, but I knew him primarily through his sons.
Two of his sons were class mates with me at all.
Vernon Dahmer., and we call him Vernon Dahmer, we call him Vernon Dahmer.
We call Vernon Dahmer. Vernon Dahmer, that's what they call him.
And Vernon Dahmer, we call him Vernon Dahmer.
Sure, I remember them quite vividly before, while I was in school.
Then when I came here, of course, they were in service,
called they left school and volunteered for the service.
And I stayed and finished my time.
I didn't have the connection with him personally, personally,
that others had, but one experience after he expired.
And there's nobody else to verify, except for me.
Several of us volunteered to just go up that way,
park side the highway and just observe.
And Mr. Charles, Phillip and myself drove up there together one night,
shortly after they burned his house, and stood watch.
Can you describe sort of a community reaction when they burned his house, killed him?
A lot of sadness, of course.
A lot of sadness.
That was very close to home.
There were groups, a group, they called them the deep guns,
and not too many people knew who they were, who was white watchman, who killed watch,
for anything, this funny thing that's going on.
The old other thing that happened to me, I think it was after he was killed.
The old other thing that happened to me that would claim my attention right now.
Somebody sprayed chemical on my lawn in the form of a cross.
Was that thing that's coming?
You know the baby?
No.
Did that worry you?
Not a whole lot, but I let my wife and baby sleep in the bathroom, I sleep in the front,
and I'm with her, with a rifle.
Did anybody else come?
Help you keep watching?
I just took care of myself.
Were you when they had the trials, the first trials, and actually a couple of them?
I was here for the first trials, and one of the guys who was given some time
was paroled by Governor (William) Waller, I believe.
I wrote a letter to him how terribly it was to parten the man.
I sent him a couple of sent to the editor, they did print it in the paper.
I was here when the last man was sent to his trial, I'd heard all of that.
Did you ever get a response from the Governor?
No, no.
I didn't get a reply, but it was in the mail, it was in the news.
Were you surprised that they were able to get the conviction in the late 60s?
Not really.
I guess you say yes and no.
At the beginning of the get-others, then I figured at some point that everybody
would be held accountable for the misdeeds they had done.
It was a conviction of...
I'm not black, you know, the name...
Sam Bowers?
How did it...
Do you have a sense of that impacted community when he was kindly convicted?
I don't know if there was a relief or not.
It had been so long.
I remember from the time the crime, the time they convicted him, I was at that child.
I was at the immediate family.
The younger people would not have had that much emotion, attachment as the older people were at that time.
What are the things that you would like people to know about the civil rights movement?
The courage, the legacy we have, the courage to keep on keeping on in spite of the arts.
Don't let their opportunity of making things better past them by.
You know, we have a lot of legacy, a lot of people who invest it in what we not call freedom.
And if we don't continue to invest in it, then will our future generation have to inspire them to keep going.
The young people today, to hear it, is sort of like a fairy tale that couldn't happen.
If I was born since then and I've gone to school and I wanted to go and live basically I wanted to live, that couldn't have happened.
But it did happen.
And we miss telling the stories because it's not in the quote unquote the history books.
It was not in history book then, but we were history. People were forced with history.
My grandpa were history.
And of course the older the grandparents get today, the less they get a chance to pass on to succeed in generation.
We were housed in for convenience.
If we were, we need to put them in the rational home.
Or if they were real sick, we just need to put them there.
But when we came on, there was no rational home.
We had an extended family, so we benefited from each other's experience.
We were there to encourage each other.
There is a better way.
And many times I would say to people, three words will solve all the eels that's in this country.
The first word is education.
The second word is education.
And by now you know the third word is education.
I lost my people a lot. I'm not educating.
You've spoken to this a little bit.
I think you just did.
But you know, you're a leader of the end of Lacey's case.
So what is it that you think of the most significant issues in the gay class?
I feel like I'm asking you the same question now, right?
At the top of the list.
What is it?
Education.
Education and what we work, education jobs, which was included in the employment, education job,
and the freedom to exercise whatever the gift and talent that you have without regards to your skin color.
And we need to do some more with our community policing.
And we're working on a community policing.
There is not a friend of dialogue between the police and the community.
Police comes from the same community, many of them that they police.
But this deal is a breakdown in communication.
So communication is very important.
People need to be heard.
People want to be heard.
And we had an experience back here that we resolved it, but it's not satisfactory.
The City Council took away the citizen forum for 90 days, ended up keeping it for 15 months.
All kinds of suggestions to go back to it.
They went on a bike when we took a record.
That was unnecessary.
We shut it down because people who have a problem communicating sometimes get very emotional.
And they got to get through their emotion before you can hear what they're trying to say.
A lot of people come to me with problems.
They don't know how to explain the problem.
But I have a listening ear.
I know how to ask the right question so that you can get it out.
And sometimes that's all they need is to know that somebody heard them.
And then now we can work on a solution.
But if you don't hear me, we got the baby's mentality.
Baby can't talk.
The only way they communicate is cry.
And if you're smart enough, you figure out whether it's because I'm cold, because I'm wet, because I'm hungry,
or because I got some kind of pain.
If you can figure it out, you can communicate.
But if you never figure it out, when the baby can't get it out, it starts striking, fighting.
And some of us become adults.
Never being able to communicate.
You were telling me before we got cut off about the people's problems, the man that you worked with on how they...
Yeah, I had his bread association for civic improvement.
And one of the members that go into, I'm going to say Dallas, Texas,
and he saw a similar project.
He and his wife came back and sold their idea to us, and we made an application with her.
And that plan cost us $121 million to put it up.
We only put up like $3,000 to get it started, and that kind of stuff.
Nobody earned, nobody got any money from it.
All the people who were privileged to work there got paid, and I never worked there.
So in some ways, it was an investment, but it was also an effort to provide housing and service.
Well, it was an investment not for individual profit, but for the community to help people to advance.
Now, all of the others were put up by private owners for investment.
Eventually, we had to get rid of it because Katrina didn't help us out the insurance, didn't pay all the damage, then long time residents, when they moved out,
there was so much renovation needed to be done.
So we had to drain our reserve.
So we were not made an inspection, so we had to get rid of it.
But the other thing that came out of that is that the first community action agency here was started by this one group.
We sent two people.
This was part of the Warren poverty community action agency.
No, community action agency for headstocks.
We sent two people to Atlanta to find out what it was about.
They came back and we formed a biracial committee and put the application in to learn that George Pittman,
who was Senator Pittman at that time, had put one together.
It had to be biracial.
Took it to Washington, ready to walk it through.
So when they started contacting those who they say they had, they knew nothing about it.
You just put people name.
Yeah. So they came back here and said, you're a tellurza, sign on to ours, and we'll walk it through.
And we said no, no.
They didn't know who they were talking to.
But we are responsible for getting it forest-owned community action agent.
It was recently known for what pays Head Start and because of the had some problems, not only on a new management now,
but that support of what come out of the freedom summer and the civil rights movement.
These are our markers.
Yeah, we progress.
The schools are still struggling, but we know these happen.
So at my age, I'm still trying to get a community-wide, unitive, police community kind of thing.
That's in the process.
But we're supposed to be talking about history, I know that.
Well, no, we're actually interested in the kind of news we're interested in, like, is there?
Yeah. So we're still trying to build a community relationship.
White, black, ministers, clergy, judges, police, men's, presidents, the universities.
And we think we'll make an understood out with that.
So that was, you know, we're here in the McCain library today.
Yeah.
I'm pretty much the same with here when it was part of keeping, so then, segregated.
What kind of changes have you seen with the University of Houston?
A tremendous change with the, you know, the population is, you know, the demographic population is just tremendous.
Of course, you got African American president, and we got that closeness.
I had closeness contact with him before he came here, but it grew out of other things.
President, who was just before me, was a lady, and I didn't have that much contact with her.
Maybe I had one meeting with her, but before him, Tim's.
I had some relationship here, but that grew out of the basketball football gang between Jackson State and USM,
where there was some alteration between some people.
So we brought that to the tension. We had a lot of back-and-forth involvement there.
And of course, since that time, now I still have a good relationship with Dr. Eddie Holloway and other persons that I hear.
I get calls from all over. A couple of incidents that stands out in my mind.
One has to do with a student from Kansas City.
Kansas City, Kansas, was on the basketball team. Good player, and he and his roommate got an alteration.
I got his job broke. The coach didn't report it, and we didn't report it.
And he and the doctor agreed that one thing happened, but the firm showed something else happened.
The mother came down intending to take her son out of the school, and he was a good player.
Initially he agreed that he, but then he said, the basketball team is going to be good this year, so I'm not saying it.
But not dead at any of that same spirit.
The other had to do with a family from Euler, so we had a daughter down here who had a roommate for a different race.
And they had some problems. So I was calling on that and got that resolved.
So I think we are making a difference. There is a difference on the campus.
Did you feel like belongs to the community?
And the campus makes a special effort to reach out to the community, celebrate and freedom from summer, celebrate and other things like that, and try to get the community involved.
The community is reaching out to them.
So I do see some progress within a unique situation that we have not had a Ferguson, Missouri here.
And that's one of the reason why the late effort was done starting from the NAACP that we want to spare this city of a Ferguson, Missouri.
There was a tragedy. It was just the flip flop of what we was trying to prevent.
And no tragedy is good. But the thing that kept us focused there, that it was a black officer and a white officer.
So we couldn't do a finger porn. You know, the thing we can get here is trying to bring people together because both she had blood in the same soil.
And the blood happened to be red. They just happened to be one officer calling it the other way.
So this is what I call being proactive. Proactive.
I live in the community. I live in a neighborhood. I love a lot of people. A lot of people know me.
There's still a lot of problems, a lot of cruelly. You know, people getting killed. But you're getting robbed and all that kind of stuff.
But it's not going to go away by itself. The community has a big state in it.
Just say whether it continues or discontinues. That's where my thrush is.
So, you talked about a number of the legacies and the things that you're still working on.
And there are other things that I'm important for people to know about, but either struggle or the work that you've done since.
Well, this is what I'm going to say now. It does not leave me with a bitterness.
But I had a great uncle who was lynched here on this bird road black in 1929.
Our great uncle was lynched.
I don't know the area that was in the Richburg Road (Forrest County).
Now, let's go out to watch. You know where the Pinebelt complex is down here off of Hardy Street, Broad Street.
If I went down Fortinet and turned just as I've passed Walmart going back in that direction, which is O'Hareway 11,
turned off with their old or Richburg Road (Forrest County) black in that way.
And the one was ever brought to trial.
Did you know about how to handle that?
Not as a child. I didn't know that. It's at the move here to this area here that I learned about that my family had spent.
I'm trying to remember how did I first learn about it.
I knew somebody approached me and informed me about it.
Of course, there's newspaper clipings and all that kind of stuff.
Who was involved in it?
Well, there are some ideas who were involved but nobody was able to talk to COVID.
Has there been any effort in this area to deal with smelchings to acknowledge or try to do any kind of stuff?
I talked to one person who was going into some deep research on it.
I don't know. I do have some notes on it.
But I can't put it together right now.
I know a few communities not many are trying to do this restorative justice.
I must have thought it would like to find out if your family member had been rich.
Just like it was them, it could have been me.
I've been in places where there's no protection out in open bone dogs, you say to speak.
You don't know what kind of reaction you want to get.
You just never know.
You just never know who's going to do something crazy.
Did you find out about that?
Was that when you moved to the area?
I've known about this now, 10, 15 years ago.
Do you have any other thoughts?
I can't think of any other right now.
Well, we really appreciate you coming and sharing your experiences and thoughts with us.
Well, I am honored to be alive.
But I can still talk about it.
It does not matter a lot, right?
Still work and still contributing.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.